heute war merkel dann noch zu gast in
der südchinesischen metropole shenzhen
das ist ja quasi das chinesisches
silicon valley für uns vor ort der
kollege albrecht humboldt der sich
offenbar schon erschreckend gut
eingelebt hat im kommunistischen china
genosse welche im gegensatz zu ihnen
passe ich mich den neuen
machtverhältnissen an
ich habe zu hause sogar schon die
passende partei gegründet die
maoistische arbeiterpartei
mitteldeutschlands kurz man wirklich
jetzt ja was werden sie denn her so
super ja dieses gefühl der totalen
geborgenheit europa macht sich in die
hose wegen datenschutz und hier sind
alle drei meter kameras mit
gesichtserkennung
[Applaus]
herr welke wien wie soll ich das
erklären ich fühle mich hier einfach
gesehen als als mensch in einigen
städten werden fußgänger mit namen auf
monitoren angeprangert wenn sie bei rot
über die ampel gehen ja da hier kommt
nämlich jeder mal ins fernsehen nicht
nur der feine herr moderator und das ist
auch nicht alles millionen von chinesen
machen jetzt mit beim sozial
kreditsystem da sammelt man rund um die
uhr status punkte status punkte gibt es
für regierungstreue essverhalten und
gute zahlungsmoral abzug gibt es für
oppositionelle äußerungen oder für einen
verschwenderischen lebensstil
da ist das geil 2020 wird das landesweit
eingeführt ich mache auch mit
denn keine verbrechen begehen reicht da
nicht ich muss dem staat rund um die uhr
beweisen
ich mag dich start man kriegt zum
beispiel pluspunkte und es kein witz
wenn man sich um seine eltern kümmert
wer viele punkte hat es dann ein
ehrlicher bürger und krawatte
leider gibt es auch sogenannte
vertrauens brecher vertrauen sprecherin
nummer eins in diesem monat war die frau
deren hund auf den rasen geklagt hat
verlangte frau wang hat jetzt hausarrest
und ihr hund lebt jetzt an einem
besseren ort in einem wok
es ist ein absoluter albtraum millionen
chinesen durften letztes jahr nicht mehr
mit dem flugzeug reisen wegen schlechten
punktestand zu kriegen keinen job oder
keine wohnung ja selbst schuld punkte
looser vertrauens cretu sekunde ein
sozial kreditsystem meldet sich ich hab
wohl irgendwas gemacht
oh nein die haben mich gefilmt wie mir
vorhin eine chinesische tomate nicht
geschmeckt hat dabei sind die das doch
die besten der welt und und dann ist
auch noch wegen mir unser kreisen
gefeiert wird und dass in china durch
das war doch keine absicht
was dafür zwar in der punkteabzug auch
leute jetzt ruft meine mutter an man
mama ich kann jetzt nicht jetzt habe ich
meine mutter beleidigt so eine scheiße
und jetzt habe ich öffentlich geflucht
herr welke rufen sie die deutsche
botschaft dann mache ich nicht
kommentieren
[Applaus]